the private wealth of King Charles III
is estimated to be 600 million pounds
but where does Britain's royal family
actually get its money from
when his mother died King Charles
inherited more than just the crown
British monarchs are exempt from
inheritance tax when they pass on assets
to the heir to the throne and the
distinction between public and private
wealth that can be blurry as head of
state the Monarch technically owns the
crown Estates a collection of land and
assets that includes Ascot Racecourse
and a big chunk of Central London
but the crown estate is run
independently its profits go to the
government a quarter of which around 86
million pounds last year is then given
back to the Royal household in a
sovereign Grant this covers staff pay
travel Communications and the upkeeper
Palaces the family also Pockets the
income from the duchies of Lancaster and
Cornwall private States made up of land
property and financial assets last year
these were worth a combined 1.7 billion
pounds this money pays the world's
private expenses and although many of
the Palaces the Royals live in cannot be
sold they have other private property
such as Balmoral and Scotland and
Sandringham in Norfolk
this mix of private and
government-funded income explains the
Royal Family's wealth but it does little
to answer thornier questions over the
monarchy's value
foreign